من وين اجيتوا اي مدينه نحن جينا من
الخرطوم برضه الخرطوم انت طالب هناك لا لا
احنا مستثمرين انا ابن مستثمر هنا كلنا
عشرين سنه موجودين بالسودان طيب انا سمعت
للاخ هناك كرتونه احنا غاد اسمه مصنع
الربيع كمان بس انا كنت استمعت للاخر
الوضع بصراحه صعب في البلد تحكي لنا عنه
هناك من اي ناحيه كيف القصف كنت قريب من
القصف من القتل عارف احنا بالنسبه لنا كان
القصف جنبنا يعني كويس حتى شغلنا الضرر
صار في نهب صار في سرقه الشوارع الجثث
يعني شفت بعينك فعلا
تقعد ثلاث اربعه ايام ما شالوها شوف نسبه
الجثث مش كبيره اها بس موجوده وبعدين اللي
بيصير انه صار في عمليه النهب والسرقه صار
استغلال الوضع اللي بيصير يعني صح انه في
قصف وصار فيه يعني بس في نهب وسرد البيوت
للصيدليات قديش قديش نسبه الامانه اذا
بدنا نحكي نشوف احنا بالنسبه لنا ماشيين
من اول مبارح عشان نوصلهم ما بعرف عنده
الخرطوم برا الى
يعني كانت جايتنا خطوره وقعدتنا هنا خطوره
بس جيتنا اامن من قعدتنا يعني ممكن انت
تكون قاعد تجيك قذيفه على البيت تقصفك
وصارت فعلا وصارت كثير وصارت مع في ناس
اردنيين هون مصالحهم شغلهم تضرر بشكل كبير
الحمد لله فش اصابات في الجاليه الاردنيه
احنا لم يسجل الاردنية الحمد لله ما في اي
اصابات والامور الحمد لله وسفارتنا الله
يجزيها الخير كانت متابعه معنا اول باول
الحمد لله على سلامتكم ايش شعورك لما اول
ما نزلت الطياره في عمان كيف بصراحه طبعا
شعور بالامان يعني احنا قلنا اسبوع انا
طلعت على شغلي يوم السبت اللي فات لما
بدات الاحداث وبديت اشتغل ما شفت الا
هالرصاص وهالضرب وهالناس وهالعالم احنا
اسبوع لثمانيه ايام خوف وقعد وقاعدين
بالبيت ومش قادرين نتحرك وفي عنا في يعني
انا في تحت يعني معي عندي خمسين شخص في
الشغل جوازاتهم واغراضهم معي انا اللي
قدامك جوازي بالخزنه لحد الان ما قدرت
اخذه في تسهيل طبعا الخارجيه لجوازاتكم
بالدخول هلا كل شيء الله يجزيهم الخير
والاردن ما بنسى اولاده يعني اكيد اكيد
الحمد لله على السلامه الحمد لله على
السلامه الخوف راح نتمنى للسودان الشقيق
طبعا انه تكون امورهم كلها على خير ما
يرام شكرا جزيلا طاهر